ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS:
Thanks, everyone.
It's really good to
see this turnout.
And I'm very excited
to talk to you today
and I'm going to talk
to you about the team
that I work on, which is
called Google Crisis Response.
And so sometimes
they say oh, so you
work on when there's a
big crisis in data center,
there's a network issue,
the computers are crashing.
No.
Actually, we deal with
humanitarian crisis.
Like a crisis-- for example,
recently the Typhoon
Yolanda-- how to
bring information
in that type of situation.
So the goal of this team is to
make critical information more
accessible in time of disaster.
What is very important
in this situation
is to have accurate information
and information that
is relevant and credible.
In particular, having
wrong information
can be even more hurtful
than having no information.
So it's important to have
the right information,
to deliver it to people
as fast as possible.
When you're in a
crisis situation,
timing is very important.
And finally,
delivering to people
however you're connected.
However you're
finding information
could be through a different
product, through your phone,
through your desktop, and using
different type of standards.
So since the team has
been created in 2010,
we've been responding
to more than 45 crisis
around the world, and
different types of crisis.
A big crisis, for example,
is this Typhoon Yolanda
in the Philippines that
happened a few months ago
that your city all heard of.
But we also get involved
in smaller crises
in terms of localization.
For example, after the Boston
explosion we got involved.
Or more recently,
this morning there
was an airplane that
got lost and that
was from Malaysia Airlines.
So right away we
got our team to be
able to put critical
information in front of people
as soon as we can.
Phone numbers for people
to call if they're
looking for information
about the family
or even for the public
and for the media.
But before I talk a little bit
more about what we developed,
I want to go back
to how this team got
started because I
think it reflects
a lot of this period of Google.
It actually all started
in January 12, 2010
when there was a 6.9
magnitude earthquake that
had struck Haiti, near by
Port Au Prince, the capital,
leading to the devastation
that most of you heard of.
There was,
unfortunately, a quarter
of a million people got dead.
The devastation in
terms of infrastructure
and for the country was huge.
The first thing that
we did at Google
was update satellite imagery.
So we had started
to do that even
before the earthquake
in Haiti, for example,
for their Hurricane Katrina.
So this is an example
of satellite imagery
that we get from our satellite
provider [? JOI ?] that
is the picture of the golf
course in Petionville, which
is not far from Port Au Prince.
That was before the earthquake.
This is the same picture
after the earthquake,
and only one day
after the earthquake.
So we could update
the satellite imagery
in Google Earth in less than
24 hours after the earthquake.
You can see in this
picture that people
started to leave their
house that was not
sure anymore-- there was a lot
of aftershock at that time--
and start to go on this golf
course, which was a safe place
to be.
And then 13 days
after the earthquake,
that was one of the biggest
camps where people went.
And actually, it was there
for one or two years.
So this golf course
was not the only place
where people went to
after the earthquake.
So there was a lot of
small groups like this.
So then you can imagine, when
you think about technology,
that just having the
satellite imagery you
can do lots of analyses and
trying to find automatically
where are the groups
and where people went.
But at that time we thought
the devastation was so, so big
that there's something
else that we could do.
We couldn't just stay
here and do nothing.
So we started first to
put some maps together.
So there was a
different organization--
like the Red Cross, for example,
put some medical facilities
together.
There was some damage
assessment done.
So a lot of data around.
People were sending emails.
There's some that
were just linked
in some website in
different formats.
But it was really hard for
anyone to find the data.
So we manually put
together these maps,
trying to put them in some
specific standards that
could be able to share with
each other, putting it in a way
that a lot of
people could access
the data without
bringing down the server.
So we created some
of these maps.
And then another big issue
that happened at that time,
and you might have
remembered, where
it was really hard to
have news from people.
I personally had family
and relatives in Haiti.
Impossible to call them for
days and even weeks after.
It was really hard
to get in touch.
And I was not the only
one in this situation.
There were a lot of people.
So some people started
to bring up some sites
with a list of missing people.
So it was replicated everywhere.
Some site just went down
because too many people
went on this site.
So we started to brainstorm
with some Googlers
and say how can we do something?
Scaling is something
we're good at Google.
So we started a hackathon
trying to bring together
all these databases,
trying to build an app that
will bring all of these things
together so that if you search
for someone, you can find
in one single place that
will aggregate all the
data from everywhere
and open so that
we could share it
with also other applications.
So we did a 72 hour hackathon
with engineers from Google
from all over the world.
We had people from
Sydney in Australia.
We had people from London,
people from Tel Aviv in Israel,
from the east coast of the
US, from the west coast.
It was like coding for 24 hours.
And 72 hours later, we
launched the first version
of Google Person
Finder to upload
this aggregation of data.
So after this
experience, many done
by Googlers that
just volunteered--
they dropped their
main projects, saying
that this is important to do.
We thought there's
so much that can
be done with technology to
help in situation of crisis.
So we went to our
funder, Sergey and Larry,
and told them, hey, there's
something we can do here.
Technology can help.
Why don't we create a team
of people, of engineers,
to focus on this
specific problem?
And we created the Google
Crisis Response Team
in the spring of 2010.
So I want to present here
what we learned so far
and what we've been developing.
So the first thing we did was--
the first question we had was,
but internet, does it even
work during a disaster?
Because that's Google, that's
what we know how to do,
is how to use best
the power of internet.
So we started to study that.
We are data driven, so we
started to look at data.
This is a graph of the
number of user query going
to Google from Haiti.
So you can see that
it's high and then it
drops on January 12, 2010.
What is interesting
here, it drops,
but the blue line doesn't
completely drop to the bottom.
There was still a
little bit of internet.
I remember 24 hours
after the earthquake,
chatting with someone who
was in an internet cafe.
So there was a little bit.
And then it took four
months to go back
to the internet traffic it
was before the earthquake.
If you take another
example of a country that
is very prepared for
earthquakes, this is Japan.
So on March 11, 2011, there's
this big magnitude nine
earthquake that I'm
sure you'll remember.
This is the graph.
So this was an earthquake that
happened in Japan, in Tohoku.
This is the graph of the daily
traffic to Google from Japan.
And what you can see
is that on March 11,
the traffic stopped
a little bit.
But it didn't stop
for that long.
A few hours later, it was up.
And so if people
couldn't use their phone,
they actually could
use the internet.
And so we know that from data.
We also know that from users.
And so this is Ruth, the
user, a Google user, in Tokyo
that sent us a thank you email.
And in the email she explains
that their desktop email system
would not go
through on March 11.
Their phone SMS
didn't go through.
Their voice didn't go through.
But Gmail connected them.
They connected them
in the company,
but also with other people in
Japan and people outside Japan.
And it was not just Gmail.
It was Facebook.
It was Twitter.
That was the entire internet
that was up and running.
We can thank TCP/IP,
which is highly resilient.
So there are some internet
that's still here.
So the next question
we wonder was,
but do people turn to the
internet to find information?
So we did some studies.
So this is the traffic of
people using Google from Hawaii.
And this is the number of
requests about tsunami-- people
searching information
about tsunami.
So you can see the spikes
after big earthquake.
The earthquake in
February 2010 in Chile
and then the earthquake
in March 2011 in Japan.
So if we zoom in on
Japan on March 11,
you can see here that
there's no one searches
information, very
little, about a tsunami.
And then, at 7:56
p.m., a tsunami warning
was issued by the
Pacific Tsunami Center.
And you can see the spike.
What is interesting here
is the top of the spike
here-- so these
are for people that
are located in Hawaii that
are impacted by the tsunami.
The top of the
spike represents 23%
of the search queries in Google.
23% of people using
Google at that time
were searching information
about the tsunami.
So people turn to
the internet and turn
to Google to find information.
So our role is to
build some tools
and to make all this
information that
is critical for these
users available.
And what is this information?
What are the needs of people?
Because say, OK,
we're just going
to go and provide
this information,
but what do people need for?
And that's a big
challenge to understand.
What people search for are
often, how bad is the event?
Do I need to evacuate?
Do I need something?
Am I impacted?
Am I impacted now, or am I going
to be impacted in two days?
Where is my family?
Where are my friends?
My kids?
Where are the people that
I was supposed to meet?
Or what resources do I need?
Do I need to go to a shelter?
Do I need to pack up any water?
Are we going to have a
risk of power outages?
So all of this information.
So for that we actually
have people on our team
go on the ground
in different places
and discuss with people
to try to understand what
are the needs to better define
what tools we should build.
And what we learned from them
is that anything for any tool
that we want to build, we
have to follow these three
principals-- simple,
standard, and open.
Simple-- during a crisis,
this is not the right time
to learn a new UI, to
sign up for a new account,
to type some
recaptcha, all of that.
And we might be laughing,
but it's very important.
And all of you who did some
UI design or-- designing
a simple UI is very complex.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
And best is even if you can
reuse a tool that people
use every day, and
then they're going
to know how to use it
during a crisis situation.
Finally, standard.
Using standard to
share your data.
Collaboration is key
during a disaster.
People exchange information
and work together.
If everyone used a different
standard for their data,
it's impossible to put all
of these data together.
So use standard as much as you
can and then open your system.
Open your data.
Make sure that everyone
can access your data
in terms of license, but
also having an open API
so you can exchange
data between systems.
Using open source
is even better,
so that people can actually
reuse what you're doing
and understand
what you're doing.
So I'm going to give you an
example of some tools that we
built and why having something
that's simple, standard,
and open makes them very useful.
So I talked before about
this Person Finder tool.
So Person Finder is a very
simple web application
developed in Python
on App Engine.
It's open source, where
you have two buttons.
You have-- I'm
looking for someone.
You want to have
information about a person.
Or, I have information
about someone--
like you want to tell your
friends that you're safe.
So you click on
a button and then
you have if you're looking
for someone, you type the name
and then you can have the
list of the people that
have been listed already in the
database with different status.
If you click on one of
these links on John Doe,
you have here details
page with the name
of the person, descriptions
that someone entered.
So for example, here I
was looking for John Doe.
And then there's Phil--
I have no idea who
is Phil, who is also
searching for the same person.
When I finally have
some news from John,
then I'm going to update
this page and then Phil,
who I have no idea who he
is and he doesn't know me,
then he'll have that
information too.
So without knowing
each other, we
did exchange some information.
So after the earthquake--
oops, I forgot.
So here we have a data API.
So why Person Finder
was successful
in different
examples was that we
have a data API that will allow
us to search, read, and write.
So we can have
different groups that
have different lists of missing
people, put them in the system,
read them, and write.
It implements a standard--
PFIF, Person Finder Interchange
Format.
So if other application
talks these standards then
we can exchange data.
And then it's open source and
you can check out the code.
When we launched Person Finder
after the earthquake in Japan,
two hours after the
earthquake, initially it
was people who started to
enter information directly
on the tool.
But we did a great
use of the API.
And here's an example.
When the Tsunami Warning was
issued, people pretty much
just ran out on their homes.
You don't have time to
grab your bag or whatever.
You just run and they
went into shelters.
And then people
went into shelters
and they were looking for
ways to tell their family
that they're in this shelter
and that they're fine.
So they started writing
on piece of papers
and put that on the
wall of the shelters.
So they wrote their name and
the name also of the shelter,
and et cetera.
Then, the few people
that had a phone
that accessed the
internet, they took
a picture of these particular
places and put them
in a Picasa album on the
web for everyone to see.
And then for every
single picture,
some volunteers from all over
the world look at the picture
and then transcribed.
You had to speak Japanese.
And then they put the
name of the shelter
and below a list
of names of people.
And then what you
can do, you can
write a simple program
that's like a for loop.
You just look and say,
if I see this name,
check if it's in Person Finder.
If it's in Person
Finder, update that entry
in Person Finder
saying I saw that name
in this particular
shelter and link it
to that particular photo.
This way you can scale
and do that a lot.
An output of that was that there
was more than 9,000 pictures
of data uploaded in this
particular Picasa album.
More than 1,000 people helped
doing the transcriptions
and 130,000 records
in Person Finder
were updated through that.
And all of that is
possible because we
used a standard, an API.
And it was open and we
could exchange data.
You don't have to be part
of Google Crisis Response
to write this small tool
that will do this upload
[INAUDIBLE] data
of Person Finder.
So having something
simple, standard, open
allow you this collaboration.
Another tool that we work on
is called Google Crisis Map.
Some data that are crucial
during a disaster are geodata.
But they are all over the place.
And they're in different
format and different sites,
and how do you put
all of them together?
So we did create something
called a crisis map.
So maybe some people saw that
in 2012 during Hurricane Sandy.
We put a map together
where you could
see the forecast cone of the
hurricane, what are the areas
to evacuate, and all of that.
You could overlap them and
have a better understanding
of how it looks like.
And then it scales.
You can have thousands
of people watching
the map at the same
time and it still works.
Again we used some
standard here.
So you can have
geodata in format
of KML, GRASS, all type of
geodata that people know of.
So that will allow you
to put some data on a map
and visualize it.
And here's an example
of how that's useful.
Just after Sandy, I'm sure
lots of you were in the city.
It was a big mess and we
didn't know what was open.
Are there gas stations?
What are the pharmacies
and the hotels
if you have no place to be?
So the New Jersey-- the
Office of Emergency Management
in New Jersey put together
a list of all the businesses
that were open.
And they put that as a
PDF on their website.
And you're like, that's useful.
So if you know
your own latitude,
longitude and parse that file
you might know what's near you.
So how much do you do of that?
But this information is key.
It was a very rich
piece of information.
So we took it and
we put it on a map.
You just put lat,
long and here you
can visualize what are
the gas station near you.
But then quickly you
say, OK, the gas station
was open twelve hours ago,
but now does it have gas?
Because again, bad information
is worse than no information.
If we tell you there's a gas
station that is open here
and you go there and there
is nothing available,
then it's worse than not knowing
that there was something.
So, we thought who
would know better
if there's gas or no than
people in the station.
So we alert people here
to update directly the map
and add a comment if they
thought there was gas or not.
And so getting-- crowd
sourcing that information.
And while we were
doing that, we heard
about another map
that was created
by some students in New Jersey
that created this Mappler map.
They actually-- so
these are the students.
They were in a
room and they were
with their laptops and their
phone, calling all gas station,
and updating some maps.
But their maps had
less visibility
because they didn't have the
visibility that Google had.
But because we use
the same standards,
then we told them,
hey, if you want,
we can just put your data that
is much better than our data
right now on the map so
that more people can see it.
So we put their Mappler
gas station on our map.
It was like two clicks, done.
But then, in there,
people still could
comment on that information.
So then, people commented
sometimes, say, oh, actually
this is closed.
And then we would send
that information back
to the students in New
Jersey to the Mappler.
So we take their
data, we display them,
we collect more data,
we send back to them.
All of that because we
speak the same language,
the same standards, and
our systems are open.
The final product I
want to talk about
is-- the main two, Person
Finder and Crisis Map,
are usually used after
a crisis situation.
How to deal, how to
help people recover.
But what if you could
tell people ahead of time
to help them prepare?
Having an alerting
system-- you have on TV,
you have the little
banner when there's
something happening that
is here, or on radio.
But what about the internet?
What would be great if the
internet could tell you there's
something going on
right now, where
you are or based on what
you're planning to do?
And what if there would
be some standard that
expressed these alerts?
It happens that there
is such a standard,
something called the Common
Alerting Protocol, CAP.
It's been developed by
thousands of emergency managers
as a way to publish their data.
It's a simple XML
standard where you
can specify what is happening,
when it will happen,
who we should alert,
what is the region.
Like there's a
hurricane in New York,
so we should warn this
particular set of people.
And what should they do?
Should they evacuate?
What to do?
So you say, oh, cool
there's some data that
is here in a specific standards.
We can do a lot with that.
So we decided to take
some of this CAP feed,
ingest, and then build these
what are called Google Public
Alerts as a way to be
this alerting system
of the internet.
So right now, we have these
data for a certain number
of countries and if you go to
google.org/publicalerts you can
see them and see what alerts
are happening right now.
So we try to make them
easier to understand.
So reading an XML file
is not that-- it's
hard to get a message across.
But then we put the
information like that.
If there's a tsunami, we're
going to put the arrival time
and put the map-- what are
the places that are at risk?
And then we can also
try to help people
discover that information.
Like for example,
on a web search,
if you search evacuation, and
we know there's a fire near you,
we're going to show
the evacuation warning
for that particular fire.
Or you could say if
you're on your phone,
then we could alert
you through Google Now.
How many people have
an Android phone?
OK.
And do people have Google Now?
A few.
So did you get some of
this winter storm warning?
Yeah, so that's our team.
So the goal here is, we
have some information.
We know where you are, so
we can push that to you.
So a lot of things are silent,
like winter storm warning.
We're just going to do
a little notification.
But if this is a tsunami
warning or tornado warning,
we might make a
noise and wake you up
because this is
something that you
have to do something
specific about
and you should know about it.
So having these-- the
hardest part of this
is actually getting the data.
So we worked on building some
tools to help these agencies.
Usually government agency
created these data.
So we wrote a few
open source tools
and you can check
some of this URL out
to see how it looks like.
So what are we doing next?
What are our big challenges?
We want to be able
to automate more
of what we're doing so that we
can respond to more disaster.
Talking about a
Google Crisis Map,
we have to manually create
and put some data in.
We're working hard to
try to make it easier
so that we could
automatically find some data.
Empower more citizens,
so more crowd sourcing.
Better engage the community
that is on the ground, that
has the best understanding of
what's going on around them.
These are people that
have the information there
that know the best
what they need.
And how to work with them and
provide some tools to actually
better understand that.
And one last thing that
we're not doing right now
is how do we do with offline?
How do we do with
people, how do we
help people that are not
connected to the internet?
How do we help people that might
not have a phone, that might--
country that have low
internet penetration?
So that's what we're working on.
And I want to finish
on this slide,
that if you're
interested, there's
a lot of communities
around crisis.
And Crisis Mapper
is one that works
on how to best create
geographical data.
This hackathon, Random
Hacks of Kindness,
is a good example where
you can go for a weekend.
Or the Grace Hopper
Conference, the conference
for women in computing.
The Google Crisis Response
participate every year
in the Open Source Day where we
work on one of our open source
tools to try to add features.
So, thank you.
So if you have any questions,
because I rushed a little bit.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering about
the Person Finder.
So I understand that privacy
is not at the top of your head
when you're in a crisis
and trying to find somebody
or letting somebody know-- but
what about when you search,
it comes up a list
of all the people--
how do you approach privacy?
Is it a concern?
Or have you thought about
sort of doing a matching thing
without having to be
able to see everybody's--
ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS:
Yeah, so that's
a very important question.
Because as you said,
during a crisis situation,
people don't necessarily
have privacy in their head.
So they're ready
to just give all--
you're looking for someone, so
some people might not realize
that they put a lot of
information there that
it's-- yeah, it can hurt them.
So, for example, when you
enter some information,
there's some information
we don't display.
We don't display the date
of birth, for example.
So we don't display it here.
There's privacy in terms of
we-- between the first version
and now, there's been a lot
of things, mainly related
to privacy.
And actually, we
work with, there's
a consortium working
on missing people
where there's different
NGOs in there.
There's the Red Cross, and
we work all together on PFIF
in particular.
And privacy is a big one.
So we added for the
records to be expired.
We also added a way for people
to lock a record in Person
Finder so other people
cannot add information.
If you create it, you
can also delete it.
Because unfortunately
we got some people
that did spam Person Finder
after the earthquake in Japan.
Some people just
put wrong comments.
You always have people that
will try to abuse the system.
But my faith in
humanity just got
hurt when I saw that, when I
saw people putting bad comments
and for whatever reason.
So we are working
on allowing people
to better control their
data, so you can actually
delete some data.
You cannot download the
entire data, for example.
So we try to do
things like this.
But that's a big concern, yes.
AUDIENCE: So, also
on the Person Finder.
I thought it was
really interesting when
you were speaking, because
I was thinking, well,
a lot of people-- my name's
very common, for one,
and I know a lot of
people have my name.
And so I was thinking,
gosh, how would you
do conflict resolution
on something like that?
Because I imagine
if a family thought
that they had found
their loved one,
and then it turned out
they hadn't, that there
would be so much blowback.
And it would be just more
hairy than it normally--
because you make a mistake
normally, it's not a big deal.
But in a crisis
it kind of affects
people in a different way.
And I was wondering if
you could speak to that.
ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS:
Yeah, so that's
in discussions that we had
internally where we could say,
oh, we can have some cool
clustering algorithm to cluster
people together.
But as you said, the risk if you
miscluster people is very big.
And we think it's
better for people
to go over several records.
And so you have
more description.
You just only have the names.
A lot of people would say
that person is about that age,
and you have black hair or
blonde hair and et cetera.
And so this way you can know
if that's the same or not,
and this is something that
is hard to do automatically.
And unless we have
something that is 100%,
we don't want to take
the risk to do that.
But otherwise you
can actually use
people that will
do that manually.
So that's in crisis situation,
a lot of people volunteer
to help.
So we actually
have a UI where you
can mark two things
as duplicates
manually and say these
two are the same.
But it's done by a human
being and not an algorithm.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
So speaking personally from our
experience in Sandy, my friends
and I are really
technically capable
and you're looking
for ways to help.
Have you seen-- do you see this
evolving into a coordination
point for one ways
that developers
can help either during
a crisis or beyond it
by building tools, or
acquiring information,
or on the other side,
people who need help?
Like being a place to
find instead of people,
but people who need help.
ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS: Yes.
So I think in the past
three, four years,
the ecosystem is changing a lot.
So before it was a lot
like, oh, the government
is on top of things
and this organization.
And they realize that
it's harder and harder
to just be everywhere.
And people locally, they
have a lot of knowledge,
and everyone is ready to help.
And during Sandy, you had Occupy
Sandy was like a great example.
Things just got
organized and they
use different technology
and all of that.
Just people volunteering
and getting together.
And so I think more
and more, so New York
has-- New York City
in particular--
they have a sort of a
task force, I think,
and they do regularly
some hackathon
to try to build some tools
and involve the community.
So it's starting.
It's still very hard
to put all of that
together because each
crisis is different.
There's also the
notion of, there's
a group here I
put-- Crisis Common.
And they do some crisis camp.
Something happens, and
everyone gathers in a place
and, depending on your skill,
you can help and et cetera.
So in that situation
there's a lot of,
sometimes you end
up doing something
that someone else did.
It's not the most efficient
part, but the point at the end
is just to be able to
do a task and if it
was done like two times, then
it's not the end of the world.
So there's some community
that are growing and growing.
So this Crisis
Mapper, for example,
has a conference every
year, bringing together
people that are doing
mapping in crisis.
So little by little, when
you're talking about the--
it's almost, what
is needed where
and the coordination
between organizations.
It's something that is
still a very big struggle.
How do we know that there's
some water that is needed here,
and the Red Cross
is going there,
but another organization
is also going there,
and how do you
coordinate all of that,
is something that
is still very hard.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for your talk.
It was really good.
My question is
about the offline.
You mentioned one of the things
you're tackling now is offline.
I come from Kenya and we
had post-election violence
in 2007 and 2008,
around that time,
and Ushahidi did a lot
of work during that time.
And because a lot of
people didn't have access
to smartphones at the time and
were just using feature phones,
they used SMS as a tool
to be able to do that.
And I think they worked with
frontlineSMS, they're called.
Have you explored that and what
has your experience been if so?
ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS:
Yeah, so that's
some discussion we have
regularly about how much
to add SMS.
So Person Finder, we actually
added during Yolanda.
We added an SMS feature.
So we do a lot of
sometimes coding
on the fly when
something happens,
when there's a specific need.
And Typhoon Yolanda was an
example where the internet
penetration was not so high,
but with the devastation
it was much harder for people
to have access to the internet.
And so we launched Person Finder
and we added a feature for SMS
to Person Finder.
So this is definitely a use
case that we have in mind
and how to best use.
We also, I personally think,
that for us, having some APIs
and having some local
groups know better
how to interface the
data coming from this API
to the local community
were almost be the best.
You can imagine also radio
is big in these places.
So having some local
groups that will
do this bridge in
between the two.
But I know Ushahidi has
been doing amazing work,
and it started with the
riots in Kenya in 2008.
So we don't have necessarily
SMS capabilities for everything,
but we try to piggyback as much
as we can on existing projects.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
know frontlineSMS
is a good API for that.
So, thank you.
ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
I'm Victoria.
Thank you for your talk.
I was wondering
how do you manage
the teams that work on this?
And how is it different
to manage a team
when there's a crisis situation?
When the stress
levels are high, what
do you do differently to manage
so things are still efficient?
ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS: So
that's a good question.
Because there's stress, but
when something happens-- so,
in four years it changed a lot.
From when we initially
created the team,
it was something
happened, everyone
was running like crazy,
we're not organized,
we were just coding all over.
And now we're much
more organized.
So for example, we have
people on pager rotation.
So when something
happens, it's not
the entire team
that does something.
So you can keep
working on writing
tools that will help you
automate most of the things
that you do.
Eventually, it would
be great if we just
have tools and people
use directly the tools
and we don't need to do
something special when
something happens.
So we also have people
in the team that are here
because they want to
work on crisis response,
so they're very dedicated.
I am actually not
managing the team.
I'm an engineer on the team.
And the team grew,
so at the beginning,
I think that plays
well to the team,
is people-- you do whatever
it takes to bring tools
or to launch something
that will help people.
If that means that you have
to spend some time manually
populating a spreadsheet because
that's the only thing that
will be possible,
then you do it.
I think we learned how to
manage the stress of working
on a topic that is hard.
So for me personally, for
example, sometimes I just
work on-- we need to
launch Person Finder,
we need to enable some SMS.
I don't necessarily
pay a lot of attention
to the situation on the ground.
Otherwise, that's just going
to disturb me too much.
So my husband sometimes tells
me, so you know, what happened?
And I cannot say.
I say, we launched
Person Finder.
We're doing that.
I cannot tell you exactly
what's going on the ground.
That's some other people on the
team that are working on that.
But it's a way, I think
also, to protect myself,
otherwise it's some really
hard situation to work with.
And it's a lot of chat, lot
of everything goes very fast.
So we have a common chat
room and everyone jumps in.
And I should have mentioned--
so we are a small team,
but we work a lot with Google
offices all over the world.
So for example, for
the Philippines,
we worked with people
from the region.
Some people in India helped.
So each time we work
with the local expertise.
They know what's
going on the ground.
We bring the technological
side and we discuss together.
Even if we never met
in person, there's
some people I always spent a lot
of time talking to each other.
I never met the person.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for talk.
This was a really
interesting talk,
and I think it brings
a lot of questions
to the surface about
public versus private.
It's different in the case
of international crisis.
But particularly for the
domestic crises like Sandy,
it seems like your
team and Google
are filling a void where the
public sector has fallen short.
Because they don't seem to
be up to date on technology
and using it for good purposes.
That's great for now.
There are some conflict
of interests in the way.
Do we want government
to do this?
Do we want Google to do this?
I'm sure your team
and the company
has the best interests
in mind, but I
feel like I sort of want
government to do this,
but I'm also aware
that they are not
even close to being able
to do that right now.
And I was wondering what
your feelings were on that?
If you think about
that, and if Google
is working with any public
sector organizations?
ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS: So that
that's a very good question.
And yes, we're working a
lot with the public sector.
So we're working
a lot with FEMA.
For public alerts, we get alerts
feed from government agencies.
So we work with NOAH.
So we work with, in Japan,
the local government
agency that provide
this warning.
And so each time we
deliver either a new tool
or had new type of
data it's with them.
And so it's really
like a partnerships.
And when we talk about Crisis
Map, this is more a tool
that they could use
to put their data.
So for example, the
state of Florida
has a preparedness crisis
map that is always here,
and that they put data on
it when something happens.
And that's why we're also
more sort of open source.
So this is something that if
you want to run your own Crisis
Map, you can run
your own Crisis Map.
If you want to run your
own Person Finder, you can.
And I think that's very
important, to keep that open.
But yeah, it's these
discussions about how much you
rely on a private company for
some information like that,
that is-- could be done
by government agencies.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Coreen Kircher.
I was actually born in Haiti.
I've been here most of my life.
And the Google response
to the earthquake
was very, very
heartwarming because I
know a lot of the few people
we were able to reach initially
felt that maybe the
world forgot them.
And I would say, no, you have no
idea how much people are trying
to do whatever
they can to assist.
In any case, my question
has to do with how can you
enable people to sort of help
put on the map crises that
are not yet in the news?
So for example, if there
are some low level things
brewing in a country
where there is unrest
and things are happening, how
do you kind of enable that?
And I know part of your
work is collaborative
with various governments
to give you information.
So if you're dealing with a
regime like North Korea, where
there are a lot of things now
that are coming to the surface,
but if there's a way to enable
those people who know what's
going on and there's just
not a lot of visibility
to the problem, how do you
enable them to connect?
And is there a
plan to help people
like that surface it to those of
you who make the final decision
to bring it to the Crisis Map?
ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS: So
that's a good question.
And in particular,
see if I can say
that it's more like
political crisis.
How can we help in terms
of political crisis?
That's something that we talked
a lot during the Arab Spring.
After in Egypt and then
in Libya and-- this
is something that
is-- I know personally
it was hard because we
should be able to help.
But something like Person
Finder, you could say.
We discussed with the
Red Cross at the time,
could we launch
Person Finder in Egypt
just when the riot started
and some people disappeared.
You have to keep in mind
about how much it helps.
So launching Person
Finder will just
have a list of all the people
that went to the demonstrations
and people are looking for them.
They might put their
different number,
or when you said
before, they might just
put all their private
information out there.
But this is public
information, so you
don't know who is going
to be able to use it.
So it's really hard to, in
terms of political crisis,
to do something and not
necessarily pick a side.
So in that case, we
can support people
that want to use the tool
because they open source.
So we can help them
rig up some tools,
but usually we don't get
involved in this situation,
even if it's frustrating.
And I think that's going to be--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Sorry, guys.
ALICE BONHOMME-BIAIS:
Last question.
Sorry.
But I'm going to
come to the reception
afterwards, so feel
free to just grab me
and just-- it's alright.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
No, no, no.
That was great.
Thank you so much.